[Musique]
la côte du nord-est du brésil un
territoire grand comme trois fois la
france
elle s'étend de sao luiz à salvador
ses plages sont reconnus parmi les plus
belles et les plus sauvages au monde
première région peuplée du pays elle a
été le creuset de la culture brésilienne
où se sont mêlés les influences
africaines indiennes et européennes
[Musique]
une région métissé où les habitants
luttent pour continuer à faire vivre
leur patrimoine historique et culturel
tout en rêvant d'un avenir meilleur
le nordiste a connu son âge d'or au 19e
siècle lorsqu ils exportaient du coton
en europe
située à quelques heures d'avion de rio
de janeiro la côte offre un condensé du
meilleur une nature époustouflante des
plages interminables une richesse
musicale et des magnifiques ville
coloniale inscrits aujourd'hui au
patrimoine mondial
[Musique]
nous longeons le littoral en bateau
jusqu'à l'embouchure du fleuve prédit ça
le fleuve de la paresse
puis nous traversons les terres pour
arriver à athis
[Musique]
un petit village la porte d'entrée d'un
des plus beaux paysages au monde
le parc des landes sèches de mme aragon
[Musique]
un désert unique spectaculaire et
lunaire
[Musique]
près de cent mille hectares de dunes
sculpté par la force des vents
et des lagons cristallins qui se
remplissent six mois de l'année pendant
la saison des pluies
[Musique]
à l'entrée du parc à timmins
1500 habitants une église une école une
dizaine d'auberge aucune route
ici on vit simplement les pieds dans le
sable
[Musique]
et c'est cette vie qui a choisi un
français pierre 48 ans un investisseur
parisien
il a eu un coup de coeur pour la région
après un voyage dans le parc il y a dix
ans
[Musique]
alors c'était comment
mais
quelques années plus tard il est revenu
il a acheté un terrain au bout du chemin
de sable pour y construire un hôtel en
plein coeur du village en bordure du
parc de l'an soldes démarrent agnant la
ferme de georges c'est le nom du petit
paradis qu'il s'est construit en hommage
à son grand père passionné du brésil
[Musique]
je me souviens encore lorsque je suis
arrivé j'ai couru sur la sur cette
petite dune et je me suis juré qu'on
aura une maison ici en fait ça a été mon
premier rêve lorsque je suis arrivé à
tignes
son rêve c'est bel et bien réalisé
il a construit sept chalets tout en bois
sur une parcelle de terre qui l'a
négocié auprès des habitants du village
[Musique]
et un petit potager a vu le jour
vous
cabossé father qu'est ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'ai déjà arroser les
plantes
j'ai commencé à récolter quelques
légumes
ça c'est comme de la menthe on peut en
mettre dans le thé est dans du lait
alors c'est intéressant ce que c'est un
peu pimenté c'est ce que je disais c'est
qu'on a on a peut-être une dizaine de
saveur différente dans les salades c'est
ce qui crée cette alchimie est là elle a
un goût de piment très fort en fait
c'est super intéressant même au petit
déjeuner en fait
[Musique]
mais construire son paradis au pied des
dunes n'a pas été simple
aucune route ne relie le village de tin
sont grandes villes du littoral
la première se situe à plus de 200 km ça
paraît simple fini mais ça a été une
aventure incroyable parce que le bois
vient d'une heure et demie de distance
en bateau on débarque sur la plage et
puis ensuite il ya des buffles qui le
transporte ici c'est son moment des
aventures comme des capitaines au long
cours qui partent comme ça pour de
grandes traversées on part pour
plusieurs années
mais lorsque ça fonctionne et je pense
que ça commence à fonctionner après six
ans le retour est tout à fait magique
pierre organise régulièrement des
balades à cheval pour ses clients à
travers le parc
[Musique]
l'expérience est unique et le résultat
garanti
[Musique]
la magie opère toujours
gilles touristes français a économisé
depuis un an pour s'offrir ce voyage
[Musique]
des immenses dunes de sable des petits
lagon
les chevaux loin c'est entre eux dans un
paysage de film plastique c'est juste
incroyable
un mélange de stars war et de lawrence
d'arabie mélanger
un croyant et qu'est ce que vous
ressentez
sa liberté en quarts la sérénité
ou alors je sais
[Musique]
ici on est loin du tourisme de masse
la zone est protégé par le gouvernement
brésilien depuis plus de 30 ans
les touristes doivent se soumettre à
toute une série de règles pour respecter
l'environnement
il est par exemple interdit de circuler
en quadricycle dans le parc ou d'ouvrir
un commerce
[Musique]
mais le coeur date insb avant tout aux
rythmes de la pêche
au petit matin pierre embarque pour les
lagunes avec les pêcheurs situé entre le
delta du fleuve et l'océan atlantique
les eaux d'attin sort regorge d'une
grande variété d'espèces
tiago a toujours des puits ici c'est son
père qui lui a appris à pêcher quand il
était enfant j'ai la partie la plus
facile je reste au bord de l'eau et
c'est lui qui va partir au large pour
abattre le le filet
ça c'est un poisson qu'on va manger
bientôt il est petit mais ça va être
délicieux
ça nous a pris deux minutes et c'était
facile et
et puis on a une petite pêche ça fait
une petite friture pour la pour le
déjeuner et là il ya un gros poisson
mais je sais pas ce que ce que c'est
qu'être c'est quoi ça c'est le baiia
coup
gros si tu
les regardes ses dents elles sont
grandes découpe
il y encore une trentaine d'années les
habitants vivaient exclusivement de la
pêche
quelques commerces ont vu le jour depuis
et les voyageurs sont arrivés mais
atkins a su garder son âme
on va le cuisiner juste comme ça
avec un peu de sel
regarde avec ce vent la flamme va
prendre tout de suite
at il servi la jupe ou du monde où les
choses sont très intenses parce qu on
est en communion avec la nature avec le
barque avec la mer avec la rivière des
animaux avec trois là est sacré une
dimension tout à fait unique faite
[Applaudissements]
à tim cela sauvage et ses paysages
immaculés
voilà donc ce qui a retenu pierres et
quelques autres aventuriers le luxe
c'est qu'ici n'y a rien rien d'autre
qu'une nature envoûtante
nous poursuivons notre voyage à são luís
la capitale de l'état du maranhao
[Musique]
le joyau historique du brésil un
quartier colonial parmi les mieux
préservés au monde
[Musique]
ses habitants sont des descendants de
portugais d'indiens et surtout
d'africains
des anciens esclaves dont il célèbre la
mémoire en cette fin de journée
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'a grandi maria lucia
ses arrière grands parents ont été
réduits en esclavage par les colons
portugais
notre tenue est composé d'un short au
choix d'une jupe à fleurs
passage d'une blouses en dentelle
voilà le collier
[Applaudissements]
ou est ce qu'on la dise
la tenue c'est un élément important de
la cérémonie
ce tissu c'était la seule chose qu'ils
possédaient
cela servait à leur donner du bonheur
pour oublier les choses horribles qu'il
subissait
ça nous rend heureux de faire cela
vraiment
et vous allez voir une fois que l'on met
cette tenue et se transforme
je ne sais pas expliquer pourquoi mais
c'est comme ça
venez venez on va faire un feu
mais faites attention à ne pas abîmer
les tambours
les faux des tambours sont chauffées
pour être accordée
le tambour de criollo une cérémonie qui
fait partie aujourd'hui du patrimoine
culturel immatériel du brésil
[Applaudissements]
ces praticiens date du xviiie siècle
elle était pratiquée par les esclaves
noirs d'une horde est pour implorer leur
divinité
ils travaillaient nuit et jour dans les
champs de canne à sucre sous la coupe
des grands propriétaires portugais
comme les ancêtres d'isabella
[Musique]
tout ça sert à se souvenir de la
souffrance de tous ceux qui l'ont
traversée c'est une manière de célébrer
la mémoire de nos parents qui ont lutté
pour que nous soyons libres aujourd'hui
danse et le temps bord c'est une
célébration
mais c'est une époque dur pourquoi
célébrée en souvenir aussi douloureux
on se rappelle que cette époque pour
continuer de lutter parce que ce rituel
c'était un des seuls moments où il était
libre
[Rires]
[Musique]
premier pays esclavagistes du continent
américain le brésil a été le dernier à
abolir l'esclavagé
[Musique]
c'était le 13 mai 1888
plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'africains réduits en esclavage sont
alors libéré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout ça c'est pour stimuler l'estimé de
soi le temps bord prouve que c'est
possible de rêver à nouveau il nous
redonne confiance on lui tous ici pour
un avenir meilleur
[Applaudissements]
s'il n'existe plus de ségrégation
juridique au brésil les discriminations
raciales n'ont pas pour autant disparu
aujourd'hui deux tiers des populations
pauvres sont des afrodescendants
victimes de l'héritage colonial ils
veulent aujourd'hui renouer avec leurs
racines leur patrimoine
[Musique]
la ville de serre louise ça a été l'une
des premières du brésil à être
découverte par les français
les hollandais ont suivi puis les
portugais
[Musique]
près de 5000 bâtiments d'époque retrace
cette période de vieilles bâtisses qui
n'ont plus de secret pour antonio
noberto
depuis vingt ans ce professeur
d'histoire arpentent les ruelles du
centre historique pour découvrir ce qui
se cache derrière les murs
[Musique]
regardez cet immeuble comme il est beau
cette architecture coloniale a permis à
sao luis grâce à l'unesco d'être classée
au patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
cette rue la rue du portugal est la
meilleure représentation des maisons
portugaise de la région
la plupart d'entre elles sont revêtus de
mozilla des mosaïques portugaise mais
aussi françaises belges et de bien
d'autres nationalités
au début du 19e siècle sao luiz devient
exportateur de coton l'un des plus
importants au monde
elle fournit toute l'europe l'angleterre
en particulier
la révolution industrielle est en marche
ces bâtiments coloniaux sont la mémoire
d'un âge d'or
[Musique]
c'est important de maintenir cette
architecture pour montrer préserver
notre histoire
surtout cela montre la période où san
luis et est une ville riche hic c'était
la quatrième ville du brésil pas
seulement en terme de population mais
surtout en termes de développement
économique merde
avant l'arrivée des français il ya trois
siècles l'île de são luis était peuplée
par les indiens les tupi n'en barre
lorsqu'il débarque en 1594 il se met
très vite l ouvrage
voici l'ancien palais du gouverneur de
la région
s'était le premier endroit occupé à san
luis par les français
avant leur arrivée ici ce n'était que de
la forêt
[Musique]
pour raconter cette aventure française
antonio a créé son propre petit musée
en hommage à un certain daniel de la
touche un breton jeune officier de
marine le chef de l'expédition
c'était le tout premier français à poser
le pied au brésil avec pour ambition de
créer une nouvelle colonie
c'est la ligne d'équateur
et nous sommes ici
c'est là que les français ont débarqué
avec ses 500 hommes ils érigent le fort
en hommage au roi louis xiii il noue des
alliances avec les indiens du pin en bas
qui voit l'arrivée des français d'un
très bon oeil comme un moyen d'échapper
au massacre des colons portugais
ensemble ils créent le premier pacte de
loi des amériques
[Musique]
ce premier pacte de loi organiser la
colonie
il inclut et même la peine de mort
c'était la première fois qu'au brésil
celui qui s'en prenaient aux indiens
encourait la peine capitale
quelques années plus tard les portugais
et reprennent la ville daniel de la
touche capituler rend les armes
c'en est fini de l'aventuré brésilienne
les indiens paie le prix fort et sont
décimés
aujourd'hui le reste de ses premiers
habitants que leur mémoire que leurs
descendants font vivre dans le marché
à travers les fruits et légumes qu'ils
produisaient sur leurs terres à
commencer par un incontournable le
manioc
comment ça va
c'est combien le kilo de manioc un euro
le manioc est un des aliments les plus
produits au brésil
surtout dans le nord d'est par les
indiens le manioc est depuis toujours
sur toutes les tables du pays en
particulière ici
tout le monde a fini par s'approprier
cette plante amazonienne
les portugais les esclaves un concentré
d'histoire dans les assiettes
san luis possède quelque chose que tout
le monde aime
la diversité culture de produits
historiques
et une population accueillante
un jour elle retrouvera sa grandeur du
passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en descendant vers le sud le nord d'ace
dévoile sa nature sauvage
des centaines de kilomètres de dunes et
de sable blanc
de longue piste de sable avant
d'atteindre
jéricho coira
un petit village de pêcheurs qui se
métamorphosent chaque été
on
les buggy envahissent les dunes et sa
population double à la haute saison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des voyageurs du monde entier amateurs
de glisse et de sensations fortes
j'ai ri comme on la surnomme c'est le
spots de kitesurf du brésil
demain
aline eu ça va on y va on part dans la
voiture jaune
go c'est parti let's go
paulo melo a grandi avec ce vent si
particulier d'une horde est qu'il a
appris à apprivoiser depuis son enfance
il a ouvert son école de kite et emmène
chaque matin les touristes au pied des
dunes
[Musique]
allez encore un peu plus
haché rico coira le vent souffle toute
l'année sans interruption
c'est ce qui a fait sa renommée
kite surf le kitesurf à participer au
développement économique de la ville
mais aussi de la région toute entière
c'est fou ce sport attire de plus en
plus de touristes du monde entier
ça
l'ancien village de pêcheurs est
aujourd'hui l'endroit le plus visité du
pays pour la glisse évidemment et son
esprit de fête il a gagné un nouveau
surnom lee visage du brésil
[Musique]
il existe à quelques kilomètres de
jéricho croire à une autre plage tout
aussi convoité celle du lagon
paradisiaque
c'est là au polo ce rang après son cours
[Musique]
ici le temps passe vite
parce que tous les jours tu fais des
choses qui te donne du plaisir
ici on a un style de vie très simple
avec peu de choses on est heureux
avant le développement de chez ricoh
coira ce lagon était un lieu de
rencontre des pêcheurs du coin
aujourd'hui leur embarcation laisser
place à des restaurants branchés tenus
par des investisseurs étrangers
[Musique]
et si cette plage est devenu aussi
célèbre
c'est grâce à un entrepreneur italien
qui a eu l'idée d'installer des hamacs
dans l'eau
wahou qu'est ce qu'on est bien
dans le nord d'est ont à cette tradition
de dormir dans des hamacs
c'est juste une réadaptation de la
culture nordestines
cet italien une super idée
imagine cette sensation merveilleuse de
pouvoir se détendre dans ce décor de
rêve
une vie simple un décor de rêve
et un rituel immuable pour tous les
voyageurs de passage
admirer du haut des dunes le soleil qui
plonge dans l'océan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le soir venu jéricho coira se transforme
et dévoile un autre visage
la musique envahit les ruelles sur les
plages les roulottes serbe cocktails et
caïpirinha
les touristes et les habitants se mêlent
et se déhanche jusqu'au bout de la nuit
au rythme d'une musique typiques de la
région le forro
ce soir c'est emberson silva qui va
donner un cours à ces touristes
brésilienne le fort ont un rythme qui se
danse à deux mais c'est l'homme toujours
qui guide sa partenaire
c'est super important d'avoir de la
coordination vous impulsez et vous
tourner en même temps et le mouvement de
la femme ne doit jamais sortir de l' axe
jamais
elle doit toujours avoir les pieds
devant
il regarde c'est ça le mouvement du faux
la difficulté que j'ai eue c'est de
laisser mon corps se relâcher
mais c'est vraiment génial
une fois que tu apprends ça c'est
vraiment agréable
honte à toi
bon
eh bien non en
[Musique]
général les touristes étrangers cherchez
toujours quelque chose d' authentiques
quelque chose qui vient de notre terre
comme le faux et le forro ce n'est pas
juste une musique c'est notre style de
vie
la soirée se prolonge dans les bars de
jéricho coira avec les élèves
où on se bat hugo
anderson est considéré comme un des
meilleurs danseurs du village
[Musique]
c'est une danse de séduction quand tu
danses le forro tu peux sentir le parfum
de ta partenaire peut te réfugier dans
son cou tu peux être sensuelle et très
proche d'elle la séduction fait partie
aussi du foro ça c'est certain
[Musique]
pour trouver le repos il faudra pousser
quelques centaines de kilomètres plus au
sud avant d'atterrir sur les plages
paradisiaques de pippa
[Musique]
un village de pêcheurs entouré de 90
hectares de forêt atlantique préserver
une faune et une flore comparable à
celle de la forêt amazonienne
[Musique]
et ceux qui la protègent ce sont ses
habitants
des volontaires comme plat des myr et
leonardo des biologistes
regarder ses feuilles d'arbres
on dirait des cheveux verts
ils font partie d'une association de
protection de l'environnement
régulièrement il organise des visites
avec les enfants des écoles de la région
pour leur parler de l'importance de la
préservation de la baie de pippa
regardez c'est la place de dauphin
le destin de pippa s'est joué il ya deux
décennies grâce à un homme un touriste
anglais fortune est tombé sous le charme
de la baie il décide tout simplement de
l'acquérir
un projet fou pour que la nature reste
intacte
s'il n'avait pas été là on serait
aujourd'hui envahie d'immeubles d'hôtel
beaucoup de promoteurs sont venus avec
des propositions et des projets absurde
pour construire autour de la bêta on n'a
jamais rien accepté
regardez la falaise
elle est constitué de roches et d'argile
regardez il ya une tortue
la baie est aujourd'hui devenue un
sanctuaire où viennent se reproduire les
animaux marins
comme ces tortues ces taches noires
visibles au loin
elles ont trois ou quatre ans pas plus
elles sont bien jeune réalité
plus tard elles vont atteindre plusieurs
mètres elles viennent ici dans la baie
pour manger
à voir
[Musique]
c'est vraiment super beau
j'adore voir les tortues marché c'est
magnifique la nature
parfois je vais sur la plage pour les
admirer
et puis je les remets dans l'eau à
l'aide
[Musique]
ici on prône aussi un tourisme maîtrisé
et vert ne pas profiter de la nature
mais au contraire la préserver pour
attirer les voyageurs
ce matin ses deux touriste argentine
parts observer les dauphins et les
tortues accompagné des deux biologistes
brésilien
les règles sont strictes
l'embarcation doit couper son moteur et
interdiction de s'approcher à moins
d'une dizaine de mètres
regarde il ya un dauphin
il est tout petit
c'est la première fois que j'en vois un
et c'est magnifique et qu'est ce que
vous ressentez
elle ment ça c'est incroyable
un autre
[Musique]
leonardo profit de cette sortie pour
sensibiliser les voyageurs
cette plage est un refuge naturel pour
les dauphins et les tortues
viennent ici aussi pour s'y alimenter
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de poissons
la multitude de dauphin fait parti des
spécificités de l'endroit
[Musique]
préserver cette nature omniprésente ne
pas céder aux sirènes du tourisme de
masse ni aux promoteurs
le nordiste est aujourd'hui à la croisée
des chemins se développer mais à quel
prix
aucune autre ville que récifs n'illustre
autant ces questionnements
recife
la capitale du pernambuco la quatrième
agglomération du pays
l'âme d'une horde est
une ville riche de son patrimoine
historique unique
fondée en 1537 elle a été l'une des
premières colonies portugaises en
amérique
son centre-ville retrace cinq siècles
d'histoire
ivan moraes conseiller municipal le
défend bec et ongles depuis plus de dix
ans
il nous a donné rendez vous sur la place
principale du centre historique
ça c'est le repère 0 toutes les
distances de récifs sont comptés à
partir de 6 ans
[Musique]
il y a trois cents ans est l endroit où
tout le monde se croise et on parler des
langues différentes on y faisait du
commerce les marins débarqués
tout le monde venait ici tenter sa
chance dans le nouveau monde
[Musique]
le nouveau monde quant au 19e siècle
récifs et est passé aux mains des
hollandais qui ont construit des ponts
et des canaux
[Musique]
la petite bourgade de pêcheurs était
devenu le centre névralgique de tout le
commerce de la région
[Musique]
m
les promoteurs lorgne aujourd'hui sur
l'ancienne zone portuaire symbole de sa
prospérité
les gratte ciel se rapproche
dangereusement
ce terrain de 10 hectares accueille les
anciens entrepôts de sucre inscrit au
patrimoine historique de la ville ils
ont bien failli disparaître
des promoteurs immobiliers ont acheté le
terrain et l'entrepôt pour une bouchée
de pain
le projet était de construire 14
immeuble de 40 étages
cela aurait eu un énorme impact négatif
sur l'histoire de la ville mais aussi
sur sa géographie
et sur la vue d'ensemble
en 2014 les habitants se mobilisent et
empêche la démolition des entrepôts mais
en novembre 2017 coup de théâtre les
tribunaux sont finalement revenus sur
leur décision
plus rien n'empêche donc aujourd'hui la
construction d'immeubles sur ces
terrains
recife une ville sous tension symbole
d'un brésil en pleine mutation
la vie l'un est aussi la capitale
brésilienne des inégalités sociales
depuis plus de 30 ans un tiers des
habitants vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté des frustrations c'est en
musique elles sont en train de prendre
forme le nordiste berceau musicale d'un
nouveau genre le rap qui est devenue la
nouvelle expression musicale d'une
jeunesse qui se cherche un avenir
et quand la nuit tombe les nouveaux
talents se retrouvent dans les quartiers
populaires des rassemblements spontanés
pour se livrer à des joutes oratoires ça
se passe un contre un et les rimes cinq
ou dix on va commencer la première
bataille de la soirée
ces jeunes viennent des banlieues
populaires les favelas leur texte
dénonce pêle mêle la corruption du
gouvernement et les discriminations
sociales de la région du nord-est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et embaucher un dauphin s'est ainsi
baisse étant tombé chez potash dans le
rallye en grèce aussi tôt ni hao et
tenta gaston cabannes affiches qu'ils
imbibent la vie d'avant
[Applaudissements]
c'est en applaudissant plus ou moins
fort que les gagnants de chaque duel
sont désignés
[Applaudissements]
anderson fréquentent ces batailles de
rap depuis trois ans lui aussi vient des
quartiers pauvres de recife
tout ça c'est la culture de la rue les
minorités dans les favelas les autres
dans les résidences de luxe
si notre cri celui des communautés du
ghetto
de la population passe
passe c'est ce qu'il veut nous faire
croire
et la culture de la rue
celle des favelas c'est la plus pure
c'est certain
ce mouvement hip hop s'est inspiré des
mouvements de contestation des banlieues
américaines
depuis quelques mois alex non pas un de
ces rendez vous c'est une des valeurs
montantes de recife
[Rires]
le hip hop c'est pas notre culture à la
base mais il est en train de conquérir
toutes les favelas dans les quartiers
maintenant tout le monde rame
les gens pensent que c'est une blague
mais c'est juste pour rigoler
mais ce n'est pas une blague un jour
vous verrez tout ça changera le pays
pour comprendre leur frustration et leur
colère nous avons retrouvé le lendemain
alex le rappeur et ses copains dans leur
quartier à recife plus de cinq cent
mille personnes vivent dans des favelas
les jeunes sont les premiers touchés par
le chômage et la violence un tiers
d'entre eux est au chômage ça va les
gars alex a grandi si élevé par sa
grand-mère ses parents n'avaient pas les
conditions financières pour s'occuper de
lui
[Applaudissements]
depuis qu'on est tout petit
nos références sont les grands du
quartier
mais beaucoup d'entre eux ne sont plus
dans le bon chemin
certains sont morts d'autres sont en
prison
le trafic de drogue c'est le fléau des
favelas brésiliennes
depuis son adolescence alex a déjà perdu
trois de ses amis proches
dary c'était un pote à nous il a été tué
le jour de la fête sainte
ce tag on l'a fait pour lui rendre
hommage
en général on fait ça compte un pote se
fait tuer
saussines ça veut dire éternelle même
s'il est loin de nous aujourd'hui il est
toujours présent parmi nous
quand il ne rate pas l'autre rendez-vous
incontournable dé fin de journée c'est
sur le terrain de foot de la favela
et j'y vais garder mes lunettes te plaît
à ce que j'adore le foot
le foot me permet d'oublier pas mal de
choses c'est très spécial c'est pas
juste un jeu pour nous c'est bien plus
que cela
quand on est petit le premier cadeau
qu'on reçoit c'est un ballon on a
toujours un ballon
on ferait le même cadeau un petit
français il ne va pas lui donner autant
de valeur
c'est dans le sang brésilien
[Applaudissements]
ne savons pas d'objets novice goven
ajouts qui sévissait peu nos alliés nos
como cadeau à chaque innovation mise en
image maïtia nous finançons mesure la
capacité nationale c'est bien kyoto il
faut y compte mais nasica cgra dos du
football c'est ça bc jura d'oprah mandat
au bout ya aimez l'asie kick ass job à
dofes à zinjibar
on
sait qu'on n'arrivera pas à changer le
brésil tout entier ce qu'on veut c'est
tenter d'ouvrir les yeux des habitants
sur la situation pour qu'ils se sont un
peu mieux
notre voyage se termine aux portes de
recife
et olinda
le joyau d'une horde est
là où le temps semble s'être arrêté
oline d'art
ses ruelles paisible ses jardins et ses
églises baroques
la ville a fait fortune grâce au
commerce du sucre
aujourd'hui on accourt de tout le pays
pour son carnaval et pour danser le
ferez vous
ou hagner et fabio le font vivre tous
les soirs dans leur poule
salut ça va j'attaque regarde tout le
monde attend ici pour danser le frevo
morlaix
voilà
[Musique]
la danse est né à la fin du 19e siècle
en pleine révolution sociale l'
esclavage vient d'être aboli le frevo
frénétique et généreux devient le reflet
de ce bouleversement
échappe pas à sa symbolique
[Musique]
réjouissant c'est ça le frevo c'est un
peu comme du maïs qui explosent en pop
corn
[Musique]
le frevo ça vient de ferveur de faire
bouillir comme si ça nous rendrait bien
chaud que la chaleur émaner du sol que
nous étions libres
est ce que je suis en train de faire
c'est comme si nous étions des ciseaux
et qu'on coupait un papier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il répète ce soir c'est pour préparer
le défilé de carnaval qui aura lieu le
lendemain pour fêter l'indépendance du
brésil
à olinda on apprend à danser le frevo
dès son plus jeune âge
messi
[Musique]
tout le monde danse ici même les enfants
bien sûr
il n'y a pas d'âge pour danser le frevo
c'est quelque chose de contagieux
moi j'adore danser le feu je trouve ça
incroyable la couleur des parapluies la
musique c'est super beau
[Applaudissements]
les danseurs ne sont pas les seuls à se
préparer à l'événement
le lendemain matin nous retrouvons
rinaldo le chef d'orchestre lui aussi va
répéter une dernière fois
il dirige la grande fanfare d'olinda qui
accompagnent les danseurs
le rythme du frevo a été créé à l'époque
sur la base des fanfares militaires il
en existe plus d'une centaine
tiago écrite aussi les paroles qui
seront chantées pendant le défilé
[Musique]
si ça c'est le premier morceau que j'ai
composées c'est en hommage à mon fils
c'est l'état qui paie formation et aux
fennecs je roulais en moto avec lui j'ai
eu une inspiration
peu importe le nombre d'enfants que l'on
à 2,3 l'important c'est le bonheur qui
nous offre c'est le plus beau cadeau
souvenir aux sony en général les paroles
du frevo raconte des choses de la vie
contat h révélé quoi des historiens oui
le frevo raconte les histoires de la vie
et wattao d'adedy dialoguer l'absence de
quelqu'un par exemple au frais
il parle de nos sentiments avant crise a
annoncé
alain bénard maintenant il faut y avait
les enfants
les 10h30
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toute la famille va participer à la
répétition
tiago a appris à ses quatre fils a joué
les différents instruments du frais vous
dans quelques heures le défilé aura lieu
une dizaine d'instruments en tous
composent leur qu'istres
[Musique]
vous allez maintenant on va commencer
continuant sur ce rythme
[Musique]
la particularité du frevo
maj c'est que ces frénétique 6 c'est un
rythme qui rend les gens heureux
[Musique]
warner et fabio de leur côté se sont
mises en route
ils sont dans la rue ils vont bientôt
défiler il faut qu'on se dépêche
[Musique]
c'est ça la traction le bonheur du
quotidien ou lindor danser le frevo
allez venez
[Musique]
cette tradition du défilé populaire
existe depuis plus d'un siècle
et à olinda le carnaval représente le
plus grand moment de mixité sociale
l'un des seuls aussi
[Musique]
non
le carnaval c'est celui du peuple
et personne ne paye pour être là
ça se passe dans la rue et c'est ouvert
à tout le monde
riches pauvres blancs ou noirs
il appartient à tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regard
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on vend maintenant c'est montrer
la beauté d'une horde est au monde
entier on n'a pas eu cette chance
jusqu'aujourd'hui on veut montrer que
dans notre région notre culture est
riche et belle
le nordeste sa culture authentique n'ont
pas fini d'attirer les voyageurs du
monde entier
cette année encore olinda et recife ont
été en tête des villes les plus visitées
du brésil
on vous l'avait bien dit l'énergie du
frevo est contagieuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là